Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call where we'll get started right away.
Remember, if you're fairly new, you can...
You enter the Zoom call muted.
So, if you want to speak in a question that you think about, if you could just wait till we get to the end here
of the questions that were submitted or you can chat in.
So, use the chat in feature of the Zoom and you can type in a message
when you'll see it appear right there.
So, all right, let's get started with a number of questions submitted.
First question.
The doctor at my IV center, so this person is doing IV vitamin C.
Keeps pushing me to do IV glutathione.
I know that you say no to this.
Why don't they understand its connection with cancer?
Well, I don't know what they're thinking.
I can only guess what they're thinking.
So, most like that, your pets or IV doctors, you know, clinicians that don't...
That treat cancer may be like this person. Maybe he sees he or she sees a lot of people that have a diagnosis of cancer.
But that's all they do is interview this therapy.
So, what can you get from, you know, to...
In the United States, what can you get to use interviewlessly?
Well, you could use, you know, a combination of nutrition, which is common for some people to do,
which I don't recommend because it's all synthetic.
You could do IV vitamin C, which is the most common thing that's administered.
You could do IV curcumin.
That's an uncommon thing to be administered.
Or you could do IV glutathione.
There's not a whole lot of other things that you could do.
You can't get B17 IV in the United States.
So, there's not a whole lot of other things that you could do interviewlessly.
So, they're trying to sell packages, really.
And glutathione is another thing that they're selling.
I'm not saying that he's pushing, he or she is pushing it just because he can sell something to you.
I know his motivation.
But for someone to make recommendations to a cancer patient that doesn't understand cancer,
yeah, I struggle with that, especially when you have said, no, my doctor who I'm working with,
with cancer says no to glutathione.
Certainly, you could share with them some of my articles, some of my videos if they would be willing and open to look at that.
But the other thing probably where they're coming from is in their mind, you know, they went to school
and said they went to the anthropatic school or car practice school or medical school or something like that.
They learned that glutathione is good to help prevent cancer because glutathione is your main intracellular antioxidant.
So, any oxidative stress within the cell is squalched by glutathione catalyst and superoxide discreetase, but mainly glutathione.
So, and it is intracellular oxidative stress that can cause cancer.
So, glutathione can help prevent cancer.
And that's all they remember from that class or from their studies.
They're not looking at how do you treat cancer?
How would you take care of a cancer patient differently than how would you prevent cancer?
Somebody already has a diagnosis of cancer.
You don't do glutathione because you could actually be helping a cancer cell stay alive.
And I've gone through that at nausea with you here.
So, I don't want to go over that again.
Yeah, lots of videos of that.
But those are the videos you could share with this practitioner because they don't know.
And this isn't like an alternative idea.
This isn't my idea.
This is well researched and well documented idea.
So, they're not looking at the research on that.
And I'm not faulting them left, but maybe just give them that information.
Next question.
Would the grass-fed beef protein powder that you carry be a good source to add protein to my diet?
I am off dairy.
So, there are good sources of protein powder that you could add to your shake.
To add 20, 25 grams of protein every time you have a shake.
That's adding protein.
That's good.
Yes, you could use that.
We also have a product called protein zine through.
It's a product made from US enzymes.
It's a low glutamine, low botanine product.
So, either one of those, you could add that to your shake.
They have a lot of people that use the Videola protein zine.
It's well liked by most people.
And they add that to their shake to add extra protein.
Next question.
Is sausage made without nitrates or nitrates or nitrites okay?
They usually still add cell results.
So, cell result has natural nitrites in it.
It acts as a preservative.
That's why they add it to different meats.
And some people, you could read different blog posts about this.
Some people say it's still not good for you because it's nitrites.
I don't fall into that category.
I think cell result is a natural form of, of how can you preserve meat?
And I think you're just fine with that.
You want sausage, preferably made without nitrites, sulfide, solid kind of stuff.
And so, it's as natural as possible, organic if possible.
Yes, they're going to add cell result as a preservative.
And I think that's just fine.
I am not taking para-clair due to my walnut allergy.
Should I be addressing parasites in other way?
So, first of all, let's address this.
Would a person with a walnut allergy be sensitive to para-clair
because it has a walnut hull extract?
Yes, maybe.
I told this person just to omit that right now,
because I don't want you having some allergic reaction to that.
You got enough changes in your life at this point.
So, I would say,
no, you're safe to just leave that out right now.
Should we add something else to add to parasites?
Now, another person, I may say, yes.
But this person who asked this question, I said, no, let's wait.
Because my concern was you had just so many changes, so many things going on.
So many things turning at the same time.
Let's just pause that for a second.
We can come back to that.
We don't even have your mosaics done.
We don't have everything done.
We don't have all the data in.
Let's just wait on that.
So I would say, let's just wait on that.
Especially if you're starting chemo.
Let's just pause that for right now.
We don't want to add too many juggling balls at the same time.
My protocol includes supplements for detoxified.
I think it's really else be added when detoxing from chemo.
I created a blog post about five or so years ago, mainly for people that aren't far patients.
And it has some different things to do and not to do while you're going through chemo.
But I really should edit that blog post and not worry about people that hurt our patients.
Because it does give you some other things to do to detox the chemo.
Now, I want to, I've switched years ago to making suggestions on a personal basis to our patients.
So if a person is doing chemo from a standard standpoint.
So they're doing chemo.
Should they detox?
Should they do things to detoxify the chemo itself?
Well, there's a theory which I adhere to that chemo really does the majority of its work within the first 48 hours of administration.
And after that, it could just be toxic to our bodies.
So after that, we do want to support detoxification pathways.
Now, I already have everybody on some things.
Should we add some things to help with that?
Well, again, what I add.
So what I make a recommendation based upon a cheek swab test.
We want to stick to that until we get some of the other data back.
When we get your genetics back.
And that shows that certain pathways indeed more support than we would add that.
Or if a person started chemo before we got their genetics back.
And let's say they just did really poorly with the chemo because we've had that before.
And that's an indication.
So if a person does chemo, let's say they had chemo on Monday.
And then by Wednesday, they were throwing up sick.
And they had to take anti-nology of medicine.
They were in bed.
You know, they, you know, it's just literally wiped them out for three days.
What does that tell us?
Well, there's a tell us point that chemo was too strong.
They need to dial that back a little bit.
Maybe that's a conversation that one would need to have with our oncologist.
Does it tell us that the chemo was working?
Well, well, not really.
It tells us that you had adverse effects of that chemo.
What it mostly tells us is that the that you don't detoxify that chemotherapy very well.
So if a person has severe adverse reactions to a chemo therapy.
That gives us an indication that you don't detoxify that chemotherapy very well.
The chemo therapies detoxified partially on the pod pathway, different cytokine, cytokine, P450 pathways, a different net pathways, MAT pathways.
So if you're reacting, people that react poorly to it, they probably have a lot of defects on those pathways.
They're just slower detoxifiers of things that have to go through that pathway.
There are some people and some people that might be listening to this call that they did six rounds of chemo and had almost no ill effects.
Maybe a little bit of nausea, but they just kind of soared right through that.
I just talked to a gentleman today that did chemo for his prostate cancer had literally no ill effects.
And he's doing great and no ill effects. What's that tell us?
Well, that tells us that he has a really good detoxification pathways from a genetic standpoint.
It sure enough we did his genes and he does have a really good detoxification pathways.
So your ability to get rid of things has to do with not just your genes, but the genes do play a big role of that.
So if you have defects on your detoxification pathways, you're going to be a slower detoxifier.
It also has to do with things beyond genetics, meaning how healthy your liver was going into this whole situation.
If you had, you know, exposed to different toxins, alcohol, you know, other environmental toxins throughout your life that damaged your liver,
then you're going to be a slower detoxifier, even if you don't have any genetic defects on your detoxification pathways.
So there's different factors, genetic and epigenetic factors that can slow a person's rate of detoxification.
And if your rate of detoxification is hindered, then you're going to have more ill effects from any toxin that you're exposed to.
So on an individual basis, then should I add supplements, other nutrition, help me detox if I don't know what my genetic pathways are.
Well, then I would go, how are you doing symptom-wise post chemotherapy?
I'm doing pretty good. Well, then I wouldn't change anything. I'm doing horrible. Okay, then we need to have a talk.
So that's how I would make that decision.
Next question. Conventional medicine states that chemotherapy can cause spread of cancer to other organs.
Would you agree? And if not, why do you think they state that?
Well, I would agree in part. So chemotherapy, so chemotherapy, remember, is an oxidizing agent.
So by definition, it's really a poison. And people have said in the alternative community for decades why would I do chemotherapy?
It's a poison. Well, I know, but that's how it works and that's why it works because it's an oxidizing agent.
Remember, cancer cells are replicating fairly unhealthy cells, cells with unhealthy mitochondria.
They're not making a lot of glutathione within that cell. And therefore, they're at a higher level of oxidative stress within a cancer cell.
So a cancer cell has much more oxidative stress in the cell than a healthy cell does.
Oxidative stress over time can cause can cause cancer, oxidative stress, if it's too high, can cause cell death, cell lysis.
So think of it as there's a graph. And there is a lethal dose of oxidative stress. So that's a line across the top of the graph.
Well, a healthy cell, you know, it's a very healthy cell, making, you know, healthy mitochondria, making glutathione superoxidist who tastes cannilace, you're getting rid of toxins within that cell.
Your oxidative stress is fairly low. You're a long ways away from lethal death.
But a cancer cell is unhealthy. It's not got adequate mitochondrial function. It's got a lot of oxidative stress.
It's really close to the lethal death threshold. So adding chemotherapy towards protocol then tips it over and breaks that lethal death threshold and the cell dies.
So chemotherapy kills cancer cells. The only catch 22 is chemotherapy doesn't spare healthy cells.
So chemotherapy is going to be taken up more rapidly by cells that have a higher metabolic rate.
Well, that's good because cancer's got a higher metabolic rate. So it's going to gobble up the chemotherapy.
Yeah, but there's other cell lines that have a high metabolic rate. Your hair follicles have a high metabolic rate.
So the hair follicles are going to gobble up chemotherapy faster than your skin cells.
So you're going to have a greater cell death of those hair follicles, thereby you're going to lose hair.
That's why people lose their hair when they do chemotherapy.
Well, what else has a higher metabolic rate as far as cell lines? Well, your immune system has a higher metabolic rate.
So the catch 22 that is more harmful to us when we're doing chemotherapy is that it affects our immune response.
So our white blood cell count is going to go down. That's why when you do chemotherapy, you have to get a draw and do a CBC to get a white blood cell count before you're
able to have administration of chemotherapy. Because if your white blood cell count is below 2.0, they're not going to give it to you.
And there's different medications that they can give you that can boost the white blood cell count.
So then you can come back tomorrow or the next day and we can do the chemotherapy and not be off schedule.
But why is the person's white blood cell count down suppressed when they do chemotherapy because your your immune system is a highly metabolic system.
And we'll take more chemotherapy and it's going to destroy those cells.
But it can damage other cells. It's going to cause oxidative stress to other cells.
If those stress those cells are already fairly ill for some other reason, it could cause death to those cells.
And then you're going to have endotoxins and you're going to feel sick and that's part of the malaise you feel and you feel cruddy and you feel like you're going to throw up and that's all the symptoms that you get with chemotherapy.
But cells that are more healthy, it's going to cause a lot of oxidative stress and that oxidative stress inside the cell caused by the chemotherapy now could be a cause of cancer.
So it creates an unhealthy system. So the catch 22 of chemotherapy is that it works to kill cancer for a lot of people.
But it also works to damage other cells and it could set you up for cancer, could set you up for lysis, could set you up for other symptoms.
Therapies that are oxidative, which are most alternative therapies are oxidative, you're going to do B17 or you're going to do protocell or you're going to do IV vitamin C.
There's a lot of different cell different therapies in the alternative spectrum that are oxidative, they do the same thing as chemotherapy, except they don't damage, they don't cause oxidative stress to healthy cells.
If you didn't have cancer and you just went and did IV vitamin C, let's pretend you said as an example, you're not going to create cancer because you're using an oxidative therapy because vitamin C though it's oxidative is not oxidative to healthy cells.
So it spares healthy cells.
So can conventional, why does conventional medicine state that keyboard could cause a spread of cancer? Because it can.
Does it do that and everybody does everybody can have chemotherapy and if getting cancer somewhere else they end up with more metastasis they end up with secondary primary cancers.
No, they don't because you have an immune system that will recover and will fight that and you're doing other things that are fighting against that try to boost this and try to build your your your body back up.
So you're doing everything again, you're to help come back that.
So they aren't just being honest and I'm surprised that you see that stated because for years they, I don't know where you saw that stated because for years they don't admit to that.
Just like they don't admit to you doing biopsies can cause the spread of cancer, but it's been proven through their own research so.
Next question, a social media I heard someone discuss the need for extra caution in the bathroom when flushing flush three times and clean the toilet after every use.
When you've had chemo so others don't get sick from the chemical the chemotherapy itself if they're spread of it.
Do you think this that that is a concern?
Well, it is a concern. You have a lot of toxic chemicals and you're doing chemotherapy. You don't you do want to be careful.
You know, you could it could make someone else not feel good. They're not going to get enough of it to cause ill health.
I wouldn't be so concerned about that, but if you had little children around, you'd want to be more cleanly than than that.
I have never really addressed this subject because I thought that you would have gotten information from the oncologist about things like this.
So I never really investigated more than I think I've had a couple people ask this question before, but we never really posted anything on it.
Some say taking zinc increases cancer cells in those with ovarian cancer. Do you agree and if not, why not?
So I do agree that there are studies that taking excess zinc can up regulate certain pathways in ovarian cancer.
It's not the same with other cancers that in fact take a down regulate different pathways with prostate cancer.
Well with with ovarian cancer, you don't want to take excess zinc for too long.
Now, I will say that one of the one of the errors that people make with ovarian cancer, they read something like they'll read this or they'll even have an oncologist say don't take zinc.
And they're ignoring the fact that 95% of the people have copper toxicity already and going completely off zinc even if you have ovarian cancer can increase the copper toxicity and increase the copper circulation and copper is a major driver of all cancers.
So it is a balancing. So you want to you have to have a two to one ratio of of zinc and copper and so that we usually measure that initially with blood tests or people have had it measured, but with with ovarian cancer, you don't want to stay on zinc loan term, but you want to be on zinc initially to help push out some of that copper.
And then you slowly will go off the zinc. So I don't remember who asked this question if I put them on zinc or not or told them to stay on zinc, but it's something that if it tested well on the cheek swap test of the second cheek swap test will we will be tested if it's still test well keep you on it, but we'll know at the second cheek swap test.
The genetic foot baths are all the rage right now on social media, would you suggest that as a detox potential? No, so there's with the true rife package, people got most people got and I had pro wave, that's what true rife called it from the from true rife.
They really when Mike Tigley are came out with that, he really pushed it as a detox tool and and it's really detox seed and that it's really, really good for you using the ion foot baths.
So understand true iotic foot baths are using ions by positively charging the water and then negatively charging the water and the good iotic foot baths, you can set to how you could run it all positive charge, you could run it all negative charge.
So an ion is a positive or a negative charge so you can run it 70% positive 30% negative vice versa, whatever you want to do as you know as the practitioner using it or whoever's administrative to ion foot baths.
Well, you know, since those first came out about 15 years ago, there's been a lot of other cheap dialogues of the market that you just put in the water you just heard about you have no idea what it's if it's really ionizing the water.
If it is what a positive charge or negative charge the idea was if you're running a positive charge you could be pulling out negatively charged ions so you could be pulling stuff out of the tissues.
Does that help you detoxify yes it does is it worth doing it well people really like it because the water changes colors and it's exciting because oh my gosh look at all that junk I just must have pulled out of my body.
Now I do believe it works we have used the ion of foot bath not that I had pro way from to right so don't don't mix this up so we have used a.
If we're not the brand that we used to use in the office there's two brands are Kodia and then this high on pro actually there's which the one we use I can't remember the one we use so.
So there's two professional models that were out there that I think were equally good so we used what we used what in the office that was a true Iotic foot bath and we did people with chemotherapy and the water would actually would actually become like.
I mean it was literally like there's lots of chemicals in that water and it wasn't like that before they did chemotherapy so I'm convinced that you were pulling out things but those companies used to distribute like color or paraplets like if it's this color you're pulling this out if it's this color you're pulling this out of this color.
Quite honestly I just don't I've I've stated this dozens of times when people have asked this question I don't adhere to the belief of that because I've done it enough with people that that's just isn't true.
And you could literally put one of those things just in the water with nobody's speed in it and you're going to get some discoloration of that water because you're ionizing it so there is minerals in that water that you are ionizing it it's going to cause a discoloration of that water so is it really a great tool for detoxification I think it could be helpful but I'm not sure it's a great tool.
Now again I said don't confuse this with the ion pro-way from true right because the ion pro-way from true right is just a way to get higher frequencies in your body and there will be some detoxification when you do that but that's a totally different philosophy.
It's not ionizing the water you're running specific frequencies through the water you're not ionizing the water at a positive or negative ion.
There can be benefits to both so but is it something you should run by an ion pro-way or an ion foot bath I would say no.
If you have access to it if you want to do it and it makes you feel a lot better doing it then I think it's fine doing it but I don't think it's necessary nor do I think it makes a giant difference in your detoxification.
If you're much better off if you're going to spend money on something like that to buy a sauna that's going to be a much better use of finances.
Get out one of those hip-hop sonas or something like that and it would be to get an ion foot bath.
In your program the goal is to understand the cause of our cancer not just to treat it are you doing that now in addition to supporting the cancer or do we focus on that some point in our cancer journey.
So when we did our cheek swab when I do your cheek swab I used to there might be people's this call that have been with me for years and years that remember when we used to tell people exactly what came up as the cause.
Well the powers that be we need the powers that want to take me to court have forbid me from doing that anymore.
So we can't put it in your binder what came up with the cheek swab as the cause.
So from a medical legal standpoint no we don't tell you that but you could get an idea by what I put you on.
If we're focusing more on detoxification it's probably a toxic source that came up if we're focusing more on killing pathogens than it was more of a pathogen source that came up that secondary so that would have been primary.
So that's what I could legally tell you.
Now you're going to see some things when we get you know when we look at your mosaics if you know we look at your mosaic tests.
It doesn't surprise me at all if a person's cause of the cancer was primarily pathogens and let's say toxins didn't even come up it was only pathogens which usually there's a mix of different things.
So it was only pathogens typically their mosaic tests of toxins which are mainly toxin tests are going to be all clean but talked to somebody recently that that was exactly the case.
So but then there's you know there's more people that toxins are the primary cause of their cancer than pathogens but it's used to be you know probably 70-30 the other way.
Years ago now it's probably 60-40 toxins over pathogens but yeah so we're still focusing on that and that is what we put you on from the cheek swan.
I asked my doctor to run a homocyste test with my last blood work and they refused why would they refused and what is it for.
Okay so homocysteed what I take a person off methyl groups so they were on methyl groups before they started with me specially.
Now there's other indications too and I'll talk about those so let's take a step back what is homocysteed.
Homocysteed is a metabolite of so in your metabolism process you take folate and you break it down into a chemical called methyl tetrahedral folate.
Now that goes into the methion what's called the methionine cycle and you make homocysteed and from homocysteed homocysteed serves a function basically the only function that it serves is it's an intermediate metabolite.
Now that breaks down through a gene called your CBS gene into system authority to then breaks down into cyst eaters and breaks down ultimately to help with your glutathione pathway help with detoxification pathways help with a lot of different things.
So remember what an intermediate metabolite is let's say your body needs to take substance A that you consume and you eat and it has to make substance E so let's take it substance A and it has to convert it into substance E but it has to convert substance A into substance B first and then C and then D and then E.
So we're looking for more E in order to do a process of detoxification let's say but the BCD are what are called intermediate metabolites so we could have excess B because the breakdown from B to C is being hindered from a genetic standpoint or from a you know there's there's needed co factors to break B down to C.
So we have excess B in our body well homocysteed is a intermediate metabolite that has to break down into other things to help with detoxification if we have excess homocysteed it can do damage to our body.
So excess homocysteed is one of the primary factors that damages our arteries so it scratches or etches the correct term it etches the endothelial cells endothelial cells are the cells that lead the arteries homocysteed etches endothelial cells which then cause cholesterol to plaque them.
So why do we get cholesterol plaques because we have too much cholesterol no it's because you have scratches you have damage to the endothelial cells not how we only cause my homocysteed but homocysteed is the main component so why wouldn't you run a homocysteed panel on someone when you're doing blood test.
Okay well if you already ran one last year and it's all normal and there don't have any other they don't have elevated triglycerides or cholesterol or LDL cholesterol or you know any other factors of cordary disease then then you don't need to run it you know every three months or something maybe you just run it every year.
So why would I ask for a homocysteed test number one if I looked at a person's past blood tests and they never had it run I often say let's get a homocysteed with that too just to make sure number two I'm dealing with cancer patients in most cancer patients I take them off methyl groups well methyl groups are do a lot of bad things but they do a lot of good things too remember nothing's all bad and nothing's all good.
Homocysteed isn't all bad you have to have some of it because you have to that's you have to break it down to to the other thing the next thing so it's having an intermediate metabolite isn't bad it's just having too much of that is bad.
So methyl groups what did the processes of methyl groups it breaks down a homocysteins through the CBS gene to system with the ID so if I took cancer patient off methyl groups and they never had a homocysteed level it concerns me sometimes let's get a homocysteed level because their homocysteed levels can go way up and we don't want the person to die of a heart attack while we're cured of cancer.
So I just don't understand why a doctor would even argue the fact even if they didn't know anything about what I just said they should know that homocysteed is a is a factor in coronary heart disease that one might want to check once in a while.
Good to say such as bothers me that these medical doctors are sitting in facilities that are multi-million dollar facilities with all this laboratory equipment and all this testing equipment at their fingertips and they don't use it and they don't even know how to use it sometimes.
Not all of them but lots of them it's like why would you even ask the question why they want a homocyste test well don't you know what a homocyste test is for.
I just don't get it sorry it just bothers me sometimes but I just I don't understand why you they would ask that question well sure we'll do a homocyste test that would be a good idea I see that you haven't had one done here I don't even see one in your file.
That's around that to see what's going on it takes how much is a cost 15 dollars you run a homocyste test and an out.
Holly jeepers sometimes it's like you're asking them for like a gold bar or something you're drawing by blood anyhow could you run a few tests that could give us some data.
I just it's just sorry everybody let's go to the next question okay next question I'm not able to hold the coffee while doing an animal.
I mean an animal for more than a minute is that bad what am I doing wrong you're not doing anything wrong.
That's not bad it's just his life so sometimes you'll never get to where you can I mean honestly I've done lots and lots of animals and I never held it more than two minutes honestly maybe it tells it five minutes once in a while.
The majority of time it was a couple minutes it's like I'm going to go matter so it's it just is what it is.
You're getting stimulus on the vangle there that's what you're trying to do with it even if you're holding it for a minute you're doing just fine just keep going.
Don't beat yourself up this not a contest nobody's rating you you're not going to get an Olympic gold for holding it 15 minutes so just do your best.
The OC want to do a bold biopsy for gene reference are are we still a no doing this biopsy by grand father died from the same would also also would you let me know when you have looked at the OC summary of anything else before I move forward.
I did look at the office visit summary and I didn't see anything else that we didn't discuss so that's why I didn't call you back.
As far as the bone biopsy I don't I'm still at odds of why they would want that unless there is you know I would just that's what I would just ask why do you need that for gene reference is that going to change the way.
Well did you use if I'm going to do chemo is that going to change what what is that going to change that's what that's the question I would just honestly ask.
Well though we just if it's if you if you can't get a straight answer no we just needed in your file well then you don't need it in my file so but if it's no that's if it's this then we're going to do this.
Well then okay now we gave me an answer and maybe we'll do that when we get to the point of deciding that we're going to do that next step.
Remember that was step number three right so it's if they gave me a good answer of why and not well this is just what we do you know that's not a good answer so if they gave me a good answer that you're going to you're going to stick
a needle in me you're going to put me under surgery just so you can complete your file or isn't going to help with the decision making process and how would it help with the decision making process what would you do different what would you find what are you looking for.
That's the questions I would ask and then I feel comfortable making the decision moving forward and by all means we would discuss that.
Okay if you have a question you want to speak in you could just unmute yourself but I'll start speaking answering some of these questions for the chat.
Is melatonin a recommended cancer hormone supplement for all or certain cancers so melatonin and so normally if you took melatonin
to help you sleep you take three milligrams maybe six milligrams but typically melatonin supplements come in a three milligram dose to help you fall asleep.
The melatonin for cancer is taken at a 20 milligram to 200 milligram dose so it's high dose melatonin.
Well melatonin at normal dose actually has some antioxidant properties but melatonin above 20 milligrams has an oxidative property so it's oxidative so again if you're we talked a little bit about that the difference
is that melatonin pro oxidative and antioxidant when we started this conversation so if that's still kind of foggy in your eyes go to the article on the website called hearticin oxidative stress to kill cancer to start typing in hearticin
and it'll pop up the first blog post read that watch videos that will help but the question is is it good for all cancers or just certain cancers.
Well melatonin at high dose is not is is can be used on all cancers so there isn't any cancer that you say no don't use melatonin high dose that I know of so it can be used on all cancers now why don't I tell everybody to do it because I do just what the cheek swam does because there's a hundred different supplements that are good for all cancers and you can't take all of them.
You may be taking 350 supplements a day so it's just a matter of what tests but if you again feel glad to I really feel like I should take melatonin too
you just want to make sure you're taking at least 20 milligrams and there's there's different brands like allergy research has one that's a 20 milligrams something in one pill so you're not taking a three milligrams supplement and have it take seven of them.
So yeah okay next question by state for lung cancer that the test decides to my brain was resolved after three chemo immunotreatments by recent brain MRI and chest PET scan this week confirms no cancer.
The ecologist is leading toward moving me to just the ketruda without any more chemo because my white blood cell code is low yeah the ketruda typically will not lower your white blood cell code it's the chemo that's doing that.
Do you have any maintenance protocol that I should supplement with the ketruda every three weeks.
Well I can't remember what I have you on but I will tell you that there is a current study going on right now at Mayo with people that are on immunotherapy and it's a study adding the aloevia immune product.
So the doctor the medical researcher doctor she it's a female who is who is doing the study with Mayo really believes that the aloevia immune is the best coupling nutrient for immunotherapy and the results are going to be another five years probably but that's just an interesting thing that's going on.
So if you're not taking the aloevia immune then that would be something to think about.
Next question can I do the foot baths if I have a pacemaker if you're talking about the ionic foot baths or the ion pro wave foot baths answers yes you can.
The therapies that you have to be careful with with an electronic device would be the PEMF so the pulse electromagnetic field therapy you have to be careful with that there's I know people and still do the PEMF on their feet with no ill effects but it's not recommended.
You just you do have to be careful with that any electrical therapies you have to be careful with the pacemaker and you certainly would do laser over any implanted device.
You would do ultrasound over an implanted device right therapy when it's used with a light bulb so you're using a Tesla tube then there's no problem with that and the ion foot bath is there's no problem with that.
What else besides the glutathione will keep the cancer cells alive and in good shape.
In a good shape that we should stay away from well you should stay away from antioxidants if you have cancer.
Now there's argument that okay my cancer is not active I've been full remission I've been full remission now for three years should I start taking antioxidants.
Well you could argue that you know that okay well you're in full remission now let's try to make sure you don't get cancer elsewhere.
So I'm not against it just because a person has had cancer at one point in time doesn't mean they could never take antioxidants again no but when you have active cancer and it is active and you don't have it in full remission or you just maybe are calling it out and everything to go on.
Antioxidants is not a good idea so it would be any antioxidants glutathione is just the primary and most active intracellular antioxidant.
So now there's some nutrients that act like antioxidants that can be good for certain cancers though so it's not just a clear cut thing but it's like lung cancer's a little bit different where certain certain things that act as antioxidants elsewhere actually help with lung cancer so it's not perfectly clear cut.
Glutathione though it is that's just across the board no matter what cancer because that is the primary intracellular antioxidant.
So again like that person who said my IV therapist wants to put me an IV glutathione it just does not make any sense whatsoever to me I don't know why they're not looking at the data there.
Okay next question you stated that chocolate is okay for me are you worried at all about the five grams of sugar that is contained in a survey of 70% dark chocolate.
You know your you can count the grams of sugar a day you know when I was in the middle of my cancer I would keep track of my grams of sugar that I consumed every day.
And I can't remember what I kept it under what my goal was there's just something I like that left brain kind of data to kind of keep track of things like that.
But you know I have a strong sweet tooth that's a that's a big downfall for me and I've shared that multiple times the zoom calls.
And but chocolate was kind of a break for me because five grams for for a stack once a day was pretty darn low so if you have that sweet tooth that you really want to fill something then it you know chocolate that dark chocolate can be a nice thing to make your life a little bit better.
So in that sense I'd say no I'm not concerned about that.
The OC was this biopsy encased the energy and stuff is not working and they need to change something.
Okay well I would just get clearer more clarification and say okay how is this really going to help.
I would need to do it if you think it's really going to help and if they give you a suitable answer for that then you don't to do it.
Certainly doing a biopsy you talk about risks and biopsies okay so the largest risk of a biopsy is when they have to surgically open up a cancer to get tissue out open up a tumor.
Some kind of mass a lesion to get tissue out in order to do a pathology report on it.
So for instance if you're sticking a needle in the breast and they're going two inches deep to the lesion and then under guidance and ultrasound they're putting the needle in the lesion and then drawing it back through the tissue it's drawing cells back through two inches of tissue.
You're dropping cells you can't help it it's impossible to not do that but it so it depends on how deep it is they're going that's a big piece.
And it depends on also if you you have to take into consideration some other things too.
Well I already have metastasis to multiple areas and I just want to find out they want to find out this data is going to be very valuable for them to find out will they do way that all into that.
You know is it is it dangerous to do a biopsy of a breast tumor that's right near the surface well probably hardly any danger in doing that as far as spread goes.
So those are the kind of things I think I would ask you know in this questioning.
I don't remember what part of the bone that they were going to biopsy and that would make a difference too.
I've seen that NLR ratio is important so I think you're talking about the neutrophil lymphocyte ratio is important can you explain.
Do they always include that test well you could configure that data if you do a CBC that's a complete blood count with a differential so a differential that measures the types of white blood cell what's my neutrophil count what's my lymphocyte count.
So yeah that ratio is important because you want that balanced right you if you have low lymphocytes and high neutrophils.
You got to go okay that's not good even let's even let's say they're both within normal range but the lymphocytes are suppressed.
Okay I'll tell you right now if you're going to do chemotherapy your lymphocytes are going to be suppressed.
If your lymphocytes are suppressed it's your lymphocytes subtypes they'll never do the subtypes of the lymphocytes or you won't get that on a CBC with a differential and I've never seen a oncologist ever run that test.
And I don't think it's necessary but the subtypes of the lymphocytes are going to be the T cells of the natural killer cells which are the two subtypes that kill cancer.
So those are subtypes of lymphocytes not neutrophils so you want is strong lymphocytes as you can.
Now if you have excess lymphocytes and suppressed neutrophils that's another those are signs so remember a blood test is just a sign it's a sign of something.
So if I have low white blood cell count that's a sign of something well I'm doing chemo.
Okay well it's a it's a effect of the chemo then that's what the sign is it's showing the effect of chemo.
Let's say I have a suppressed white blood cell count and I'm not doing chemo I don't even have cancer.
Well then that's a sign of something else typically a chronic infection.
If I have elevated white blood cell count that I look at the differential to give me further sites on elevated white blood cell count is a sign of an acute infection.
And then you look at lymphocytes versus neutrophils if the lymphocytes are high and the neutrophils are low.
I just said that was good for cancer but that's not good when the site is something different.
So that's a sign of a viral infection if the neutrophils are high and the lymphocytes are suppressed that's a sign of a bacterial infection because you have elevated white blood cells and elevated neutrophils or elevated lymphocytes and suppressed neutrophils.
So blood tests are just signs of something but if you're doing chemotherapy you're really looking at the total white blood cell count.
And yeah looking at the differential I have low white blood cell count let's say post chemotherapy and I have low lymphocytes post chemotherapy.
Oh no that's not good well it isn't good but it is what it is so you're doing things to build up the immune system.
Well what can I do to build up the immune system? You're already doing everything you can there isn't any like magic missing supplement that's going to boost your white blood cell count.
Now there are some drugs that will stimulate white blood cell count because they stimulate the growth of white blood cells that you know people have argued that is a Taoise.
The right thing to do know what will boost the white blood cell count if you you know able to continue to do chemotherapy but it's not a natural way to stimulate your immune system.
You need it to grow normally. The problem is that the chemotherapy is not going to down because it's also highly metabolic.
So yes you can look at the ratio and calculate the ratio or you don't need to calculate you're just looking at that ratio through the differential.
But most people that do chemotherapy that are going to have suppressed white blood cells are also going to have suppressed lymphocytes because that's the most metabolically active line of the white blood cells.
It really will affect the neutrophils so much it will affect the monocytes, the acidophils, the vasophils that's going to really affect the lymphocytes.
Any other questions? Remember you can unmute yourself if you want to speak question or very welcome.
Okay with that we will say goodbye for the night. I know that I'm praying for all of you and we covered your prayers for us as well.
Thank you so much. God bless you and we'll see you guys next week.